[Applause]
[Music]
Indonesia is a country famous for having
a headbanger as a president I'm sure
other presidents of other countries love
heavy metal too but nobody shows his
love for this genre as much as Joko
Widodo even Judas Priest invited him
publicly to one of their concerts but
make no mistake despite being a Judas
Priest fan mr. Widodo aka jokowi
is not a big fan of breaking the law
just check out this news
Indonesian president pays $800 from
Metallica gift the important thing here
is not Widodo slow for Metallica Reds
the fact that he has paid $800 from his
own pocket to keep a gift you see when
you are the presidents of a country it's
common to personally receive foreign
dignitaries and celebrities in such
cases the etiquette says that visitors
should give a symbolic present to the
leader artworks antiquities or in this
case a rare edition of Metallica's
Master of Puppets album as you can
imagine these kinds of persons can
generate conflicts of interest
that's why in most countries it's
illegal for the official to accept such
gifts usually they become part of the
states heritage and they can be
exhibited in national museums and things
like that but in this case we don't
really want it to have this Metallica
record being the president's he could
have broken the law and taken it for
free in a country like Indonesia this
wouldn't even make the liquid news but
he decided to do the right thing and pay
a fee to an Indonesian
anti-corruption Bureau in order to keep
us and really something like this it was
kind of unique for Indonesia we're
talking about the birthplace of the most
corrupt politicians in history and I'm
not exaggerating literally the most
corrupt man in history according to
Transparency International was one of
Indonesia's former presidents this
explains why in April 2000 and 1980 five
million Indonesians voted to reelect
Joko Widodo for another term he's
revolutionized the country for good and
we're not talking about a small country
here it is the most populated
muslim-majority country in the world
with a population above 255 million but
by far is one of his greatest objectives
welcome to the jungle Indonesia pics
site for new capital city
yes Indonesia has announced that they
will move their capital by 2024
you don't hear news like this every week
of course it's not the first time
something like this has happened
Brazil Nigeria and Kazakhstan have also
changed their capitals just to name a
few however the case of Indonesia has a
very interesting story behind it if
you've been following visual politic for
a long time you might remember this
video where we told you about
Indonesia's impressive growth after
decades of military dictators and
obscenely corrupt leaders sucking money
from the stage like a swamp full of
hungry leeches the Indonesian state is
finally able to invest all of this
started with Joko Widodo the man who
seemingly
has no history of financial skullduggery
[Music]
this is a tax money going to the
Indonesian Dear Leader's golden toilet
seats it's actually starting to be spent
where it really makes a difference in
infrastructure so the question is how
does Widodo want to move the Indonesian
capital what's wrong with the currents
while and most importantly of all can
you really do it while today we're going
to answer all of these questions but
before we do let's take a look back at
the history
Jakarta the sinking city Indonesia
gained its independence from the
Netherlands in the year 1949 soon they
realized they had a bit of a problem and
just take a look at this Indonesia
consists of about 17,000 islands so vast
is this country that the distance
between the eastern and western most
parts is over 5,000 kilometers or 3,100
miles if you didn't think that that was
enough the population is over 260
million that's always twice as many
people as in Russia and you can imagine
that it's a very difficult country to
govern this situation has also had less
obvious consequences as Erik will now
tell us as you can imagine Indonesia
needs very expensive infrastructure to
connect all those islands and right now
it simply doesn't exist so what's the
outcome of all this most of the
population is concentrated on the island
of Java and the capital Jakarta is
overcrowded as you can imagine Indonesia
needs very expensive and expensive
infrastructure to connects those jungle
covered volcanic islands and they don't
have that so what's the outcome of all
of this most population is concentrated
on the islands of Java and the capital
Jakarta is massively overcrowded so on
the one hand we have a city that
receives more and more people every year
that has no money to build sewer
networks and roads so it's no surprise
when things like this happen
[Music]
Ricardo foots us five billion dollar
annual bill for traffic jams think about
it today there are almost 30 million
people living in Jakarta's metropolitan
area since City Hall hasn't built almost
any new piping 30% of families haven't
no running water at home so what do they
have to do to get water to drink while
they build illegal wells and this is two
serious consequences first the water
they get from these wells is dirty and
often toxic secondly it changes the
consistency of the grounds beneath the
city which has resulted in news like
this Jakarta the fastest sinking city in
the world the asleep Jakarta was built
in a very swampy area but with so few
enforced regulations the whole city is
currently sinking at a rate of 15
centimeters per year as the water
beneath the earth is sucked out half a
Carter is below sea level and the
population won't stop growing in ten
years it's expected to surpass Tokyo
currently one of the most populous
cities in the world so what can be done
well our friends Joko Widodo has a
radical solution and that's move the
capital not the city of Jakarta itself
of course just the seat of governments
[Music]
but no he's not just going to name a new
city the capital he's going to build an
entirely new one in the jungles of
Borneo this might sound a bit silly but
it actually does make a lot of sense
think about it this way if we move the
governments and national institutions
somewhere else all the civil servants
will move with them too and with them a
lot of indirect jobs they're also going
to move as well and that's going to
spread out Indonesian developments okay
but there is a problem the move like
this one is extremely expensive building
a city from scratch takes an absolute
ton of money and the question is does
Indonesia even have enough money to do
this well let's find out
Joey's legacy yes
governing Indonesia is a hard job but
there are upsides this country has a
cornucopia of natural resources gold oil
gas wood exotic fruits and spices you
name it it's probably on one of those
17,000 islands and as you already know
because I already told you a thousand
times here at visual politic having
natural resources can be a blessing and
it can be a curse in many cases the
money that you get from that wealth ends
up in the pockets of a dictator and this
is what happened with sakano the
founding father of the country after two
decades in power he became one of the
wealthiest men in his time and his
successor wasn't much better
General Suharto was a military dictator
who held power for thirty years and also
became one of the wealthiest men on the
planet here you can see him on the cover
of Time magazine in 1999 how Indonesia's
long time boss built a family fortune
we are talking about approximately
fifteen billion dollars of embezzlement
bribery and looting the state coffers
yes this man became their rich from
being the leader of a country in 2004
transparency international ranked the
most corrupt politicians of all time and
he won first place the greed of
Berlusconi and Lula da Silva is no match
for this man's insatiable campaign of
theft as you can imagine all this money
is simply going to a politician's pocket
is money that didn't go to
infrastructure or anything else for the
public good
that matter so what happens when the
politician stops stealing while
surprising things look at this
impressive feat of development that the
Indonesians are going to enjoy this news
is from March of 2019
[Music]
Indonesia's first subway opens in
traffic choked Jakarta yes really a city
with the national capital and
metropolitan area with 30 million people
had no metro you can imagine why the
Metro has taken more than 30 years since
it was first plant and the big change
that made it possible can be summarized
in two words
Joko Widodo with him mr. Carter's
governor the construction started and
now it has finally been finished with
him as the president's this is pretty
much one of the cornerstones of his
administration infrastructure projects
he has a mega ambitious plan of more
than 300 billion dollars to build
infrastructure all over the place more
than three thousand kilometers of
railroads highways seaports and airports
many trips have already been reduced to
a third of what they took before imagine
the difference when it comes to
logistics and passengers
but wait a minute because not everything
is sunshine and rainbows here there is
something missing in this formula and
this is private investments
as you can imagine such ambitious plans
need a lot of money and private money
would be a great help in this regard
this explains partly why despite widows
promise of 7% annual economic growth the
country has been growing at a rate of
just 5 percent the truth is that
Indonesia's very closed country if you
have a company and you want to do
business there you must partner with a
local company many industries are still
in the hands of the state and this
explains in part why foreign investment
still only accounts for a 1.5 percent of
the GDP a figure is quite low when
compared to other Asian countries
[Music]
and we have to add to this the labor for
example salaries in this country a 45%
higher than in nearby Vietnam and the
severance for firing a worker is the
world's third highest in this regard we
dodo is not very different from his
predecessors in fact he seems very
determined to scare away investors with
things like this world's biggest gold
mine nationalized in Indonesia all this
is bad news because Indonesia will
really need a lot of investment if they
really want to build a new capital think
about it this way nowadays the capital
is on the island of Java where 60% of
Indonesia's GDP is concentrated the new
capital will be on the northern islands
of Borneo which has just 8% of the GDP
change in the capital will certainly be
missed where Dodos legacy will be his
magnum opus building projects and it
will not be easy according to the
government the total cost will be 33
billion dollars that's the price of two
Olympic Games Widodo has already said
that the government can fund only 20% of
this the other 80% will have to come
from private investors
[Music]
and the reality is private investors are
not going to come if they don't do
big-time reform to their antique
business systems so now we want to ask
you what do you think about with Dodos
moving up the Capitol well its help
Indonesia climb out of poverty and would
you like to change the capital of your
country well please leave your answer in
the comment section below also don't
forget to visit our friends from
reconsider Mediacom the podcast that
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine also don't forget that we
publish brand new videos every week so
please do subscribe to this channel and
hit that Bell button so you won't miss
any posts and if you like this video
give it a thumbs up and as always I'll
see you next time and if you want to
learn more about politics and here even
more of my lovely voice you can join us
at me consider media we have a podcast
at reconsider mediacom slash podcast see
you there